all right internet people we are live on
rumble youtube and the blaze and
obviously uh the big news of the day is
the kyle ritton house not guilty verdict
which dropped about 20 minutes ago
if you're watching me right now i doubly
thank you because i know that everyone
online is live right now everyone's
talking about it everyone's screaming
about it everyone's crying about it
everyone's applauding it whatever your
position might be but we're going to try
to unpack it in the sanest way possible
here for about 20-25 minutes and joining
me today to break down the trial and the
reaction and some of the media
shenanigans along the way is author
senior columnist at townhall.com and
lawyer and my buddy kurt schlichter kurt
it's your first time on the reuben
report how did this happen
why did it take so long i don't know
dave i'm a little concerned you said
we're gonna break it down with sanity
and clarity and yet you have me on
i'm a little confused i thought i am
overjoyed
you know as a guy who's worked in the
justice system i grew up in my mom
became a lawyer at 36 in the 70s on the
kitchen table she became a district
attorney she became a judge
uh
and her pithy comment on kyle was i
don't even know how they filed these
charges and then i've been a lawyer for
nearly 30 years so um
and i i know i know that just because
they call it the justice system doesn't
mean that it's necessarily a place you
go to get justice justice was sort of
served today it would have been better
served if this kid hadn't been put
through hell for uh a year
yeah so you know the way i've tried to
cover this over the last two weeks is i
didn't actually did not do a ton on it
and people kept asking me why i wasn't
touching it as much i was covering more
of the media circus around it i was
talking you know we played some of the
stuff like when the prosecutor got
basically smacked down by the judge for
saying that kyle didn't have a right
to silence to not incriminate himself
some really crazy stuff what would you
say was sort of the craziest thing that
happened during the trial
uh the the whole thing was an unbroken
uh
series of insane events dave this is
this is not how trials usually go i mean
trials are usually very boring uh they
come in they put on their case and then
the jury renders a verdict then
everybody goes home except maybe the
defendant if it's criminal case
um
this was something completely different
this was a series of
uh and be charitable errors by the
prosecutors one after another after
another and you're thinking
how can these guys do this
to comment that i uh
a defendant didn't
uh uh speak when he was when he had the
option to exercise his right to be
silenced i mean that's like that that's
like bar review bar exam stuff it's not
hard you just don't do it
uh shenanigans involving evidence like
the drone footage
uh witnesses not being identified they
remember that the mysterious guy who
kicked kyle
they said we don't know who he is but
apparently they didn't know who he is
uh lying to the jury i mean blatantly
making idiotic uh
asking idiotic questions that you don't
know the answer to
uh and having witnesses go no uh he said
blank you and pointed the gun at him
yeah i mean i i'm looking at that and
it's just
these guys are supposed to be
professional prosecutors i mean if
they've been professional they wouldn't
have charged them in the first place
but they just it is a series of
unprofessional inept incompetent
screw-ups uh i i think
you know i mean you know like far be it
for me to defend the justice system but
they're really giving the justices from
a bad name here
i mean the prosecutor really was
extraordinarily bad not only the stuff
that you just mentioned there but at one
point he blamed violent video games and
that kyle plays video games he also said
the thing about oh well he brought the
gun so in essence he's automatically the
bad guy as if just because you have a
gun in and of itself um
this guy like could it have been any
worse could he have been any worse
well
you know i i think if he convened in a
council of renowned bad lawyers
to
vet every option and see if they could
find the worst possible decisions to
make perhaps they could have done a
worse job uh but but you know he did
pretty well all on his own screwing this
up look a professional prosecutor first
of all would have looked at it and said
this is a sure loser
i just don't see myself
getting uh
12 citizens to find beyond a reasonable
doubt on any of these counts i mean two
of the counts got dismissed at the
threshold one of them because it simply
didn't apply as a matter of undisputed
law even though even the d.a said yeah i
guess he could have a gun legally i mean
that i just
i i every time i see these guys circus
music plays in my head so so going on
the assumption that most of the people
watching this and let's say most of the
people that aren't purely partisan hacks
think that roughly the right thing
happened today what do we do about the
split in the media because this just
happened 20 minutes ago but for the 10
minutes that i was sitting here before
we started you know i'm looking at
twitter msnbc there melting down all of
the lefty blue checks they're screaming
this is about white supremacy again he
was a white kid who shot three white
people i mean this thing
it's just so extraordinary but what do
we do about this split i'm much more
concerned about that really than the
specifics of the trial you know what i
mean that we're really living in two
different worlds right now and that most
likely it's going to be a pretty violent
couple days in kenosha
well look dave i think figuratively we
need to beat their brains in again
figuratively i don't want to be accused
of uh
promoting violence but uh i i i do
accept the accusation that i want to use
this as a club to figuratively
uh club the media into submission they
have been a disaster on every level uh
they have uh
foregone any pretense of objectivity and
gone full activist but of course i could
have said that two years three years
four years ago
the fact is we need to use this as a
teaching tool for people who are not uh
red pilled
so to speak we need to use this as
a
training aid for folks to understand
what the media is all about the media
wants to support the liberal democrat
uh establishment
in the giant class war that is uh
roiling through america right now and
you know when we got 12 people
normal people
people who didn't find an excuse to get
out of jury duty but in their own kind
of beautiful
naive credulous way said i'm going to
show up and be do my citizens duty and
i'm going to try and figure look these
guys didn't walk in there and go screw
them
you know we're
i'm finding we're finding them not
guilty and walk out
that would have been making a statement
i think what they did was their job and
i find this to when i do trials
juries really want to by and large do
the right thing they take this stuff
seriously and i gotta tell you if you
ever have a chance to go down to a
courthouse even a civil case you know an
auto accident a rear ender and watch the
jurors talk and you'll see his
cross-section of americans uh especially
in places like los angeles many of them
are naturalized citizens and the thing
you get i mean we're jaded and cynical
because we we wade in this cesspool all
the time you know we see that we see the
garbage we see the lies but you know
these people get there and they go
they'll say you know it's it's it's hard
for me to give up a week or two of work
but this is you know this is what i'm
i'm proud to do this because i'm an
american citizen and this is what we do
and i i want to find the truth and i
think that's what these people did they
asked questions they reviewed the
evidence they
brought home the jury instructions which
had me shaking my head i i didn't get
that but it's pretty clear they took
this job very very seriously and and
really wanted to come to what they a
decision that they could live with thank
god it was the right decision but you
know i'm kind of proud of them because
they had to know that they're going to
go through hell you know we had uh msnbc
following them trying to track them down
they're going to be hassled they're
going to be lied about joy reid's going
to talk about how they're tools of white
supremacy
and
the fact is they're just regular
americans who uh still believe that this
believe that the system works and while
i i might have some arguments with that
uh especially concerning what's happened
the last few years there's something
beautiful about that kind of
normal american patriotism that makes
them want to go in and do a tough job
and try really try
to to to get to the right decision as
they see it based on the evidence yeah
you know that's a really nice way to
frame it because i think people look and
they go oh they've got seven women and
four white people and
it's just like they're just robots
they're not actual people and they're
only there to serve their own political
interests and i don't think that that is
what the average person is you mentioned
the msnbc thing i mean they're in a lot
of crap because they basically sent a
journalist a little unclear how it all
happened to follow the jury van i mean
just absolute insanity but are you
worried that for the people that want to
burn the system down and want to burn
our cities down that because the outcome
was in our view correct
this is just more proof to them that the
whole thing is corrupt and evil and a
patriarchal white supremacist
monstrosity
well i don't worry about that dave
because everything that happens or
doesn't happen is going to be
interpreted by them in a way that they
see as increasing their power so it's
irrelevant what objectively happens we
know how they're going to spin it what's
important for the it what happened today
is not important for the people who hate
us
because they were going to weaponize it
one way or another it's important for
the people who aren't in the struggle
yet who don't who who really don't want
uh to be in the kind of cold civil war
that i think we all agree we are in
uh these are normal people i wrote a
book about a militant normal saying
they're normal people who just want to
live their lives they don't like
quote-unquote politics they they don't
like people arguing and being obnoxious
to each other they just wanna they just
wanna live their lives have their houses
you know watch their tv take their kids
to soccer and you know walk their dogs
and live normal lives
what this shows is
that there are forces out there who want
to disrupt that and the forces aren't
the guys like kyle
the forces are the people who interfere
in juries i mean you know almost
everybody's been
dragged into jury duty
and everybody understands how serious it
is and everybody understands
instinctively how wrong it is to try and
tamper with a jury which i i don't think
that's an unreasonable way of
characterizing what msnbc did
uh
so this is a teaching moment
for the unbased the un conservative woke
the people who who have been able to
stand out of the fight
as for the people who are in the fight
like i said they're going to weaponize
it anyway it's white supremacy uh if
they lose it's uh white supremacy if
they win
it's uh uh
it's
they will they will move on to the next
faux outrage that they're uh going to
leverage to increase their own power we
need to be aware of their game and we
need to block them and today we block
them and tomorrow we've got to find
another way to block them we can't give
up the fight right well i suppose the
first way to block them going forward at
least for the rest of today is make sure
that there's law and order on the
streets not only in kenosha but
in the other cities so we'll see about
that
what do you think kyle's legal options
are now because let's not forget he had
his gofundme that was up to raise funds
for his defense was taken down by
gofundme the quote-unquote president of
the united states joe biden called kyle
rittenhouse a white supremacist again it
doesn't matter what you think about this
trial there is absolutely no evidence
that he is a white supremacist i have no
doubt that he is not what do you think
his legal remedies are at this point in
terms of
defamation suits going after gofundme et
cetera et cetera
uh well let's let's talk about the
defamation angle uh because there have
been some defamatory things said about
him look i i defended uh defamation
cases i uh helped uh and it's out in
public so i'll talk about it uh i
defended ben shapiro in texas in the
clock boy uh lawsuit we won that and won
a judgment in ben's favor
um
i've also brought defamation actions and
uh i you know i've taken the trial got
multi-million dollar verdicts when i
look at the defamation case when people
bring them to me and say kurt have i
been defamed i said maybe
but you have a terrible case and you're
going to lose and after that i ask for
the facts of the case because defamation
is properly the hardest kind of lawsuit
to win it's just very very hard
uh and it should be because of the first
amendment
uh does he have a case he may
uh i have a feeling just a gut
that in some venues particularly
conservative ones
uh defamation cases are going uh
definitely
it's going to become easier to get
defamation cases through defamation the
problem with defamation cases is often
is this a fact or an opinion opinion is
protected no matter what hey if i say uh
you know uh kyle rittenhouse is a
scumbag okay
protected no matter what because you
can't really measure that if i were to
say kyle rittenhouse is a member of the
american nazi party he has a uh he has a
card and has paid dues and that's not
true well that's a fact because that can
be proven or not proven and maybe that
is a defamation action there's some
other elements to it um
what a lot of these things are is
generic name calling like white
supremacy the simple fact is what's
white supremacist mean now anyway i mean
can you actually measure it
everybody's a white supremacist to these
hacks it's become almost meaningless and
the law recognizes that and basically
says well you know you call somebody
white supremacist no one's really i mean
it's an opinion and no one's really
gonna care because everybody calls
everybody a white supremacist it's kind
of irrelevant so i think you'll have a
hard time doing that uh i don't see him
uh currently having an action against
the gofundme people uh maybe if i look
deeper i could find something using some
of the consumer laws uh i think what's
gonna have to happen with big tech like
the uh gofundme folks is
new laws that basically
require access
and i'm i'm an advocate of it
yeah all right so actually let's go
there for a second because not
specifically about the trial but just
sort of this all fits with this sort of
cold civil war you're talking about and
the big tech component of it and the
media component of it and everything
else um do you sense we're getting some
wins here you know it feels like okay
there's a cultural moment that's maybe
happening today we got a cultural moment
and a political moment in the virginia
governor's race a couple weeks ago yes
that maybe suddenly there is a feeling
oh we're starting to get a little bit
braver we're getting a little louder
we're not just going to hand the keys
away
uh i think people were waking up dave
like i said there is a look americans
by and large guys like you and me we
enjoy politics we enjoy getting in the
you know in the oil and wrestling a
little bit most people don't want to do
that most people find that kind of
unsavory and kind of tacky and they just
want to live their lives but if they are
drawn into politics if they are forced
to do it like those moms in virginia a
lot of them were democrats they didn't
want to they didn't want to have to go
down to the school and spend their
evenings yelling at the school board
because uh a little caden came home and
informed them that they were uh
you know their their lives were
meaningless because they were uh based
entirely upon slavery or other you know
racist nonsense that crt promotes they
didn't want that but they were forced
into it people are getting forced into
it it's become
something this this this giant woke
moment has begun infiltrating people's
normal lives that's kind of the line
if it's out there at the colleges and
it's just college kids fighting among
themselves over their bizarre identity
politics okay
they can live with that but when it
comes to their house when it threatens
their livelihood when it starts
affecting their kids well then they
can't hide from it and they're not
hiding from it as we saw in virginia
uh we see politicians jumping on board
eric schmidt in missouri for instance
pushing back at jpmorgan chase for
cutting uh trying to cut off uh
uh banking services to a conservative
organization jp morgan back down we see
josh hawley candidates like jd vance
uh uh
ron desantis pushing back on this using
the law to make it very clear that you
can't discriminate on the basis of
politics here in california
there are laws
that already protect employers or
employees from being uh discriminated
against for their politics and i don't
think it is a big step to expect that we
will see movement
to
force corporations not to discriminate
on the basis of politics any more than
they do on race or
gender or sexual identity or any other
irrelevant factor
we are not going to allow ourselves to
become second-class citizens because we
don't agree with what the swells in
marin county
uh santa monica and manhattan think
and they're using their power against us
dave they're using their corporate power
they're using their uh legal power
they're using governmental power well we
got governmental power too and we're
going to take back the house and the
senate next year and things are going to
change
kurt are you saying that it we're just
nice they're still not going to leave us
alone i can't believe it
i thought if they're just nice
this is a fight dave somebody's got to
win somebody's got to lose i propose we
win that's my strategy
uh one more for you because i know you
got another hit in a few minutes um are
you are you hopeful that calmer heads
will prevail for the next day couple
days like you know there's there was
plenty of time if you were a mayor or a
governor in a
city or state to prepare for you know
potential violence here it's a little
unclear to me how much preparation
people did or maybe some of them
actually want the violence i wouldn't
put it past some of these mayors
especially
do you think we're gonna see some
violence over the next couple days
uh i don't think we're gonna see any
violence because i don't think it serves
uh
the democrat party's interest let's face
it antifa blm uh the scumbags that uh
uh kyle rittenhouse killed these guys
were part of the military militarized
wing of the democrat party as soon as
biden came in they disappeared we didn't
hear no word out of them now i was a
officer in the california national guard
i'd come back from the gulf and
immediately i was dumped into the los
angeles riots so i know a little about
what's going on i know a little about
civil support to military operations
wrote a law review article about it have
an ops map up on the wall over there
from what i did in san diego uh there's
an infantry battalion for the wisconsin
national guard on the ground there many
of those guys are combat experienced uh
if they are allowed to do their job
there will be order on the street but i
don't think there's gonna be a problem
because i don't think the democrats see
an advantage
uh i don't think the establishment sees
any benefit from having violence today
it was beneficial in 2020 they were
using it to intimidate people to some
extent it worked now it just makes it
look like uh that desiccated old zombie
masquerading as our president uh will be
out of control so i don't think we're
going to see it funny how that works i
know it's very bizarre something
happened i can't remember what in the
last 10 months that suddenly the riots
and the burning downing cities and the
special autonomous zones they all
disappeared i'm going to have to think
about that kurt i appreciate you doing
this last minute and uh it's good to see
you hopefully in real life one of these
days and i'm going to continue on for a
few minutes without you kurt schlichter
we're going to link to all your stuff
down below my friend
all right guys so i briefly want to tell
you you know i had mentioned yesterday
that we were going to have uh lawyer and
legal expert harmeet dillon on for
today's episode and we were going to
cover uh the written house trial
assuming that the verdict was in or even
if it had not been in uh we were also
going to talk about the osha mandates
and the vaccine stuff and all that uh
and then harmeet actually contacted me
about an hour ago and said that there
was a little ethical issue because she
had done a tiny bit of uh work and
conversations with some of the written
house
defense people so she just didn't want
to complicate things she didn't think it
was going to be a major issue but i
didn't want to create a headache for her
and she's she's deeply ethical and
decent uh so that's why we didn't have
harmeet on but i absolutely will have
her on in the next week or so to talk
about the vaccine mandate stuff which is
now all held up if you work at a company
that is demanding you get vaccinated
because the federal government's telling
them that they have to force you to do
it it is simply not true anymore so uh
we'll we'll follow up with harmeet on
that stuff uh but i hope kurt gave you
some insight into a little bit of the
legal stuff and you know he's good on
all the the cultural stuff and all that
i want to say one other thing uh before
i let you go for the weekend which is
i'm going to try my best today not
online to uh add fuel to the fire uh
even though the result of the trial is
obviously in line with what i think was
supposed to happen i do not think kyle
rittenhouse was a murderer who set out
to murder people i think he was a he was
a good kid who got a little over his
head and some bad things happen and we
live in these very very strange times
and unfortunately half the country is
going to believe one thing because of
the media framing and half the country
is going to believe something else
but i'm going to try my best and
sometimes it can be very hard especially
on twitter so michael maybe don't give
me my phone back today can you hang on
to my phone i don't even know where my
computer is anymore so
i'm going to do my best not to add fuel
to the fire and maybe that will be my
message to you guys too as we head off
to the weekend because uh you know
everyone's going to going to try to
score all their political points and
cultural points right now
but you know for those of us that in
this moment
we got the win so to speak right like we
believe that justice prevailed um
maybe maybe uh being a little
magnanimous in that might be good that's
kind of what i'm feeling at the moment
uh all right guys i think that's it have
a good weekend everybody and if you want
to play along with dog pictures and food
pictures and
music that i'm listening to and all
sorts of stuff you can join us at
reubenreport.locals.com and by the way
right now you can get two months off an
annual membership if you sign up at
reubenreport.locals.com
have a great weekend and uh look sanity
prevailed that's pretty good like take
that with you on a friday i'll see you
on monday